Cheese makes people bring each other happiness.
I want to fu*k now.
The thirst for the cheese is real.
I will take a shower in cheese.
I'm from Wisconsin I fu*king live for this sh*t.
Twinkies are like cockroaches.
The only things left after a nuclear holocaust.
Oo look at that.
I would like to reiterate that is this is fu*king amazing cheese though.
uh huh.
When I was out in Aspen on a ski trip.
Fondue!
I never have these burgers, like ever in my real life.
I do.
This is what the Swiss made this for.
But it tastes so good.
But with like a McDonald's burger.
Oh, what if we do one of these?
Oh yeah!
A little date night.
Can I have yours after, if you're not going to..
Fondue!
Oh god yes.
I'm going to put it in the middle
He's going for it.
Mmm cheers!
Cheers!
Oh my god.
exquisite
I don't know what is wrong with me, but I really like this
I'm doing another.
Fondue.
Fon-definitely-due
What's next?
I hate pickles.
How do you hate pickles? Maybe you'll like them with cheese on it.
Alright, that is a fair point.
Oh my god.
It just tastes like part of a sandwich.
Why does it taste like a penis.
Tastes like dick.
Fondue, do it all day.
Fondue this,  go fondue this
I'm going to vomit.
I haven't been able to swallow it yet.
I'm going to throw it out.
I can't even swallow it, hold on.
Now i'm like sad.
Yes! Yes to all of the things we just did.
Except for the things you said no to.
I don't even care about that.
I got the cheese sweats.
Yeah, or should we say it was fun.....do